les universités des mairie de l'Ouest
parisien 2023 bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur tv78 pour cet événement et
depuis les pyramides du port marlyy au
programme de l'umop 25 conférences
thématiques des tabler ronds des
ateliers 70 intervenants et près de 2000
participants et toute la journée sur
tv78 des émissions spéciales qui vous
sont proposées on a commencé tout à
l'heure avec la rénovation énergétique
des écoles mais aussi à venir des
entretiens avec les personnalités
politiques qui sont présentes pour ce
rendez-vous on va présenter avec mes
deux invités qui m'ont rejoint ici sur
ce plateau installé au cœur des
pyramides du Port Marly cette édition
2023 de l'union de de C de ces
universités des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien alors pour présenter mes
invités on a Jacques kozovski bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes président de
l'Association des Maires des hautes
scènes maire de la commune de Courbevoie
et vice-président également de
l'établissement public territorial Paris
Ouest la défense et à ma gauche pierre
fond bonjour vous êtes-vous le président
de l'Union des Maires des Yvelines maire
de la commune de Sartrouville président
de l'agglomération Saint-Germain boucle
de scène et j'ajoute également que vous
êtes vice-président du conseil
départemental des Yvelines alors
messieurs pour commencer si vous le
voulez bien on va prendre la machine à
remonter le temps et et revenir à
l'édition de l'an passé pour commencer
il y a un an ici même vous parliez d'un
contexte je vous cite plombé quelque peu
plombé à cause notamment des craintes
des élus alors plus particulièrement sur
les difficultés financières liées à
l'énergie aux matières premières et
aussi plus généralement à l'économie en
généralah quel est le moral des troupes
tout simplement cette édition 2023
est-ce que le contexte s'est amélioré ou
au contraire est-ce qu'il est empiré ah
le contexte ne s'est pas
amélioré en grande difficulté vous
parlez des fluides en ce qui concerne
notre ville de 4 millions en 21 nous
sommes aussi à 100 millions en 22 donc
ça c'est pas du tout disons arranger
donc on a de plus en plus de difficultés
en plus vous parliez des finances on a
eu aussi disons des augmentations pour
les fonctionnaires et c'est une chose
bien entendue qui est très grave qui
très bien et nous l'acceptons simplement
c'est 4 millions d'euros aussi donc
petit à petit petit à petit on
s'aperçoit qu'on a beaucoup
d'augmentation sans avoir les recettes
si vous voulez en face Pierrefond les
les années passent les difficultés
augmentent persiste oui je peux que
confirmer ce que ce que dit Jacques et
plus globalement d'ailleurs les communes
se retrouvent comme les ménages français
c'est-à-dire confronté à l'inflation
confronté à des augmentations de prix on
peut parler énergie comme on parlait on
en parlait l'an dernier mais quand je
vois par exemple les problématiques sur
les cantines scolaires avec
l'augmentation des prix qu'on ne peut
pas répercuter sur les familles on est
dans la même situation donc une
situation financière de plus en plus
tendue il y a un an ici même on parlait
des conséquences directes sur les
communes de la guerre en Ukraine on
parlait notamment des conséquences en
matière d'énergie il y a eu un événement
assez catastrophique aussi cette année
pour les communes qui est celui des
émeutes urbaines qui se sont déroulé fin
juin début juillet 140 communes en
île-de-fance qui ont été touchées j'ai
envie de dire une mauvaise nouvelle de
plus avec des stigmates qui se voi
encore parfois sur les communes al il
faut pas se méprendre on n'est pas là
pour se plaindre on dit simplement c'est
des chiffres réels si vous voulez on
essaie bien entendu de réagir à partir
du moment où on a des dépenses faut
qu'on essaie de faire des économies donc
on vient pas pleurer on dit simplement
attention on va pas pouvoir continuer
comme ça éternellement alors vous venez
pas pleurer mais quand même ce contexte
des émeutes urbaines n'a pas arrangé
aussi la la situation on l'imagine ben
d'abord ces émeutes c'est un contexte
qui est dramatique dramatique au sens où
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu pendant 3 jours la
volonté de certains de détruire toute
une série d'équipements publics et
privés également puisque des commerces
ont été des entreprises pillées sur
l'ensemble du département moi j'ai un
chiffre que je trouve affreux je crois
qu'il y a eu 280 en France 280 groupes
scolaires brûlés en l'espace de 3 jours
c'est-à-dire pour les communes
concernées l'obligation de de
reconstruire ou de retrouver voilà donc
c'est un contexte terrible c'est un choc
extrêmement fort alors bien évidemment
on a tendance après à oublier à passer à
autre chose à tort quand je vois dans
les ivelines par exemple la commune de
verrière sur quatre groupes scolaires
trois détruits plus d'autres équipements
enfin c'est quelque chose d'inoui et que
nous n'avions jamais connu qui vient de
passer là ouais la commune de laavrière
où les é les élèves ont dû même faire
leur entrée dans dans d'autres locaux et
et grâce à des financements de la Région
du Département de l'État pour per aux
très grandes difficultés de la commune
et ce n pas une commune isolée il y en a
beaucoup comme ça donc on est vraiment
dans un contexte qui est un contexte de
plus en plus tendu qui est difficile et
même si on n'est pas là pour se plaindre
les maires les élus sont au premier rang
pour essayer de faire face et de
répondre aux demandes de leurs
concitoyens bon vous faites la la
transition j'allais vous poser la
question ça montre une fois de plus que
le le maire est en première ligne et
parfois seul face à ces problématiques
le problème est là c'est que on a connu
des périodes où on avait beaucoup plus
de facilité on nous écoutait un peu plus
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas donc il va
falloir quand même réagir et réagir avec
qui donc on essaie de poser des
questions par l'intermédiaire de nos
sénateurs de nos députés mais les
réponses ne sont pas toujours ce qu'on
voudrait et il avait et Pierre a tout à
fait raison on a connu une période
difficile he ne SCE que pour quand on a
les émeutes de Nan terre on fait
beaucoup de difficultés pour nous et
pour tous on a essayé de d'améliorer
disons quand même la sécurité mais la
sécurité ça aussi un cût et ce cûp ben
disons qu'il faut toujours l'assumer
donc ça devient très très difficile
franchement alors tout au long de ces
émissions il y a des étudiants de
sciencesp Saint-Germain en lait qui vont
venir poser des questions directement à
nos invités on va commencer avec un
premier étudiant qui va nous rejoindre
c'est Léo thbao je vous en prie Léo
venez vous asseoir sur notre plateau ici
au aux pyramides euh Léo qui avait une
question sur notamment le phénomène de
démission qui peut intervenir chez chez
les élus là dernièrement oui le le
président de l'association des mè de
France a alerté dans le Figaro sur sur
la grande démission des élus plus de
4000 depuis 2020 donc j'avais une
question qui était un peu double comment
lutter contre cette grande démission et
comment prévenir la crise d'évocation
des élus municipaux à venir alors je
pense qu'il faut d'abord regarder dans
certaines régions c'est pas partout
pareil je pense que quand vous êtes dans
un petit village ce qui n'est pas le cas
dans les hautes scènes bien entendu
quand un petit village on peut se poser
des questions quand on est dans les
hautes scènes on parlera les ivelines
pour Pierre on a quand même pas de
démission on a des gens qui veulent
arriver à faire quelque chose tout
simplement parce que ils se sentent
aidés vous commencez fait une démission
c'est quand vous avez frappé à toutes
les portes et toutes les portes se sont
fermées
Pierrefond oui on a on a un phénomène ce
phénomène existe hein et pas seulement
en ce qui concerne les maires mais
l'ensemble des élus municipaux les
conseillers municipaux les maires
adjoints ce qui est vrai c'est que il y
a une difficulté inhérente à la fonction
d'élu aujourd'hui dans sa relation avec
la population qui peut être très
exigeante on a parlé des problèmes de
moyens financiers et de difficultés à
faire et essayer de répondre aux
demandes qui sont nombreuses il y a
aussi quelque chose qui à mon avis
devrait être à notre porté c'est lutter
aussi contre les normes et la complexité
on avait une petite réunion tout à
l'heure avec des élus on voit bien que
par rapport à ce qui se faisait il y a
plusieurs années aujourd'hui pour mener
un projet c'est des années en plus donc
c'est pas seulement le coût c'est
également la procédure administrative
qui s'est complexifiée qui s'est
rallongé avec de multiples recours
possibles et donc pour l'élu qui porte
des projets comme pour le citoyen qui
attend l'amélioration de sa vie
quotidienne il y a une certaines
incompréhension et pour certains de
l'assitude y a une choseet d'ajouter
parce que on n jamais en parler c'est
l'indemnité des élus dire ah oui quelle
catastrophe non il faut savoir si vous
voulez l'indemnité des élus dans des
villes elle ne permet pas à un couple
avec des enfants de vivre s'il n'a pas
un deuxième mandat ça sera difficile ou
alors il est obligé de continuer son
travail qu'il avait mais être MRE dans
certaines communes plus le travail en
plus on y arrive pas donc il y a
peut-être aussi quelque chose à voir en
réflexion alors je sais quand on parle
toujours de cela on dit oui mais les
élus gagnent gagnent non c'est facile
vous regardez sur Internet et vous voyez
tout de suite l'indemnité des élus
d'ailleurs c'est pas un salaire vous
remarquerez c'est une indemnité donc ça
aussi ça peut jouer aussi beaucoup parce
que vous pouvez pas prendre disons votre
responsabilité en prendant tout le
travail d'une mairie sans de l'autre
côté avoir au moins quelque chose qui
puisse vous permettre de vivre
donc c'est pour ça aussi que certains
élus se disent après tout pourquoi
donner plus alors que je n'aurais pas
autant rester dans mon travail donc il y
a peut-être aussi cette partie là de
démission merci beaucoup Léo et dans
quelques instants et un nouvel étudiant
de Sciences Po qui nous rejoindra sur
sur ce plateau je vous laisse partir
tranquillement c'est aussi des maires
alors malgré aussi ce contexte tendu des
maires qui sont aussi malheureusement
pointés du doigt dernièrement alors un
exemple c'est la la hausse de la taxe
foncière dans leur commune quand vous
entendez Emmanuel Macron le président de
la République dire que ce n'est pas la
faute du gouvernement si la taxe
foncière augmente que c'est les communes
qui décident et qui que c'est je cite un
scandale quand des élus osent dire que
c'est la la faute du gouvernement ça
vous inspire quoi
Pierrefond vous savez un budget communal
c'est comme un budget familial il y a
une partie recette une partie dépense
euh la dépense elle est en hausse dans
tous les domaines même si vous à la
rigueur vous ne faites rien come on le
disait vous allez payer votre gaz votre
électricité vous allez payer vos agents
et et voilà et donc la dépense augmente
en face qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme
recette
gouvernement du du du précédent
président a quasiment supprimé les
dotations globales de fonctionnement
pour la quasi totalité des communes
c'est plusieurs millions par
collectivité publique qui a disparu donc
rester des des ressources fiscales la
disparition de la taxe d'habitation qui
est sûrement très sympathique pour celui
qui paye c'est un drame à double niveau
d'abord parce que ça fait perdre aux
communes la maîtrise d'une partie de
leur recette et ça renvoie uniquement
sur les propriétaires la contribution
fiscale au fonctionnement des communes
dans ma commune par exemple à sartrville
les propriétaires c'est 52 % 52 % des
gens payent pour la totalité des service
publics consommé par l'ensemble des
habitants donc ça crée un biais et une
injustice et ça c'est la loi donc voilà
alors les communes qui ont dû augmenter
les taxes de de les taxes foncières
c'est parce qu'il y a pas d'autres
solution et si vous prenez au av déjà
une hausse légale en plus mais
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe et
c'est très bien l'État décide d'une
augmentation du point de la fonction
publique justifié pour suivre
l'inflation sauf qu'il ne prévoit aucune
recette de l'autre côté et donc comment
plus payer les fonctionnaires municipaux
les agents municipaux sans avoir de de
possibilité d'action sur les recettes
donc les gens sont coincés alors
qu'est-ce qui va se passer soit il y a
une augmentation de la taxe foncière
soit il y a des suppressions de postees
c'estàdire qu'il va falloir ir supprimer
des agents dans les crèches dans les
écoles maternelles dans les différents
services pour garder un budget je
rappelle quand même juste une chose
qu'il faut que tout le monde est bien en
tête et je sais qu'ici aux universités
tout le monde l'a c'est que
contrairement à l'état nous n'avons pas
le droit de voter des budgets en déficit
des budget de fonctionnement et donc là
où l'État empreinte chaque année 3000 et
quelques milliards d'endettement pour
payer ces dépenses de fonctionnement
nous on doit les équilibrer donc il y a
pas d'autrre solution pour beaucoup de
communes il y a de moins en moins de
Levi pour assurer les
comm tout à l'heure je vous parlais donc
des difficultés que nous avions financiè
et je vous disais de sa que les flu je
vous rappelle quand même de 4 millions
on est passé à 100 millions on la même
chose si vous voulez pour l'augmentation
des fonctionnaires c'est 4 millions de
plus il y a bien un moment il faut se
poser la question alors comme on a
simplement comme on a plus de recettes
disons il va bien falloir faire des
économies comme comme dit Pierre on fait
des économies mais le problème c'est que
les administrés veulent toujours la même
qualité de vie ils ne veulent pas que
vous puissiez diminuer donc il faut
essayer de faire le maximum alors c'est
vrai si on a le personnel la masse
salariale est difficile si on enlève du
personnel il y a des travaux qu'on va
pas pouvoir exécuter il y a des
chantiers qu'on va pas pouvoir suivre
donc vraiment on est en difficulté donc
faut pas dire le maire se l pas le matin
disant qu'est-ce que je vais faire pour
augmenter mes impôts c'est pas du tout
ça essaie de gérer le mieux possible on
essaie de gérer comme on appelle en père
de famille mais vous quand vous allez
faire vos courses vous apercevez aussi
que d'un seul coup le cadit a augmenté
vous faites des économies vous achetez
pas et ben nous on essaie de faire la
même chose alors je le disais édition
2023 de lumop qui s'est ouverte ici donc
au pyramide du port Port Marly pour
terminer cette émission on va parler des
des objectifs on le dit sans cesse
chaque année il y a il y a un maître mot
c'est échanger peut-être aussi je sais
que ça vous tient à cœur JAC kozovski de
faire remonter des problématiques aux
personnalités politiques qui sont
présentes mettre mot échanger au cœur de
ces journées pour pour les élus qui sont
présents oui et porter aussi une parole
c'est-à-dire que c'est un lieu où on
peut se retrouver on peut apprendre des
choses d'ailleurs tout à l'heure en en
voyant visitant des d'entreprise on a
aussi appris beaucoup de choses donc
c'est c'est un lieu de savoir c'est un
lieu d'échange c'est aussi un lieu pour
porter une parole et des élus nadis
nationaux viennent nous voir nous font
cette amitié c'est intéressant d'avoir
cet échange et et qu'il puisse avoir
pleinement conscience aussi des
difficultés de plus en plus fortes des
communes françaises faut pas s'y tromper
les communes en France existent avant
l'État le tissu national français c'est
le tissu des communes et c'est ça qui
font de notre pays et donc il faut que
nos communes puissent avoir à la fois
les moyens et les espaces juridiques
leur permettant de travailler et donc je
disais des personnalités politiques
présent qu'est-ce que vous allez leur
dire aujourd'hui Jacques kzovski vous
savez d'abord la grande majorité des
personnalités qui viennent ce sont les
préfets les Présidents du Conseil
départementaux président conseil
régionaux président de la nationale de
de l'Assemblée nationale ils connaissent
nos difficultés simplement il est bon
qu'on leur dise ça soit pas uniquement
par le courrier qu'on leur explique ils
le savent bien entendu et ce qui compte
c'est que maintenant on puisse être
écouté on est souvent entendu mais pas
écouté et on aimerait bien que les
difficultés que nous avons elles soient
vraiment entendu et qu' on puisse avoir
des réponses parce que il y a des
réponses on va pas pouvoir continuer à
laisser les maires en difficulté c'est
pas possible c'est la France qui est en
difficulté donc il va falloir que l'on
trouve des solutions les solutions ne
peuvent venir que du gouvernement et des
des personnes qui nous représentent on
va terminer avec un dernier tour de
micro avec une question plus ouverte et
qui va vous être posée par Emmanuel
Jean-Étienne qui est également étudiant
à sciencecesp une question sur le rôle
de maire oui tout à fait vous êtes
revenu sur les difficultés qui s'pposent
au Mair dans le contexte actuel depuis
les dernières les élections municipales
crise du covid crise énergétique crise
démocratique même peut-être alors je me
demande qu'est-ce que représente pour
vous la fonction de maire aujourd'hui et
peut-être double question quelle est
l'importance selon vous de cette
fonction pour les citoyens Pierrefond
bah c'est un peu ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur l'existence de la commune le
maire c'est entre guillemets le chef de
la commune c'est-à-dire qu'avec lui il y
a des fonctionnaires municipaux il y a
des élus il y a un conseil municipal
c'est un lieu de démocratie locale pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens c'est le
principal lieu de démocratie parce que
c'est le lieu où on connaît en général
l'élu qui habite dans la commune donc il
y a ce lien extrêmement concret et très
direct et d'ailleurs au cours de nos
mandats nos citoyens nous parlent aussi
avec beaucoup de de proximité des
problèmes y compris parfois personnels
qui rencontrent dans leur vie il faut
faut voir que le maire c'est vraiment
une sorte de médiateur et et et et
d'éléments extrêmement forts de la
démocratie locale et général c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne c'est l'élu que nos
concitoyens voient le plus et c'est un
élu qui a un pouvoir mais comme le
disait Jacques tout à l'heure il faut
pas qu'il se trompe c'est-à-dire les
contraintes de plus en plus fortes qui
pèsent sur les élus réduit aussi la
capacité à faire faire et il peut y
avoir une sorte d'ambigué avec des
concitoyens qui pensent que le maire
peut tout et des maires qui sont
confrontés à des limitations à les
limites de plus en plus fortes de leur
action le mot de la fin avec vous jacqu
kzaskii oui je crois que c'est tout à
fait vrai vous avez la plupart du temps
des administrés qui viennent vous voir
en disant Monsieur le Maire vous êtes
mon dernier recours c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ont tout essayé et donc il se trouvent
seul al ils attendent une réponse c'est
pas toujours cell peut-être qu'il
souhaiteraient mais enfin on leur répond
parce que aujourd'hui dans le monde
actuel qui vous écoute même vous qui
vous écoute est-ce que vos parents vous
écoutent peut-être je le souhaite mais
c'est pas toujours le cas donc là quel
que soit leur problème et quelquefis
comme dit Pierre ce sont des problèmes
qui sont très personnels qui serait même
presque disons difficile qu'on donnerait
à un médecin mais le médecin il faut le
payer le ma faut venir le voir
tranquillement puis je terminerai aussi
par autre chose vous faites sciance po
pensez que demain c'est vous la France
donc en faisant Science Po vous devez
dire qu'est-ce que demain je peux
apporter à la France c'est sérieux ce
que je vous dis c'est c pas des gens de
mond ce qu'il vont faire la France c'est
vous donc les questions que vous nous
posez c'est bien mais essayez de voir
peut-être de vous mettre un jour à notre
place et si j'étais à leur place
qu'est-ce que je ferais mais vraiment
allez-y j'ai d ça à vos collègues
d'ailleurs de science pro allez-y c'est
vous la France on a besoin de VOUS pas
trop de pression sur sur les épaule
d'Emmanuel Jean-Étienne en tout cas tout
à l'heure il y aura une thématique sur
notre plateau tv78 sur la réforme du
statut de l'élu faut-il réformer ce
statut de l'élu merci Jacques kozovski
merci pierre fond d'avoir participé à
cette émission les universités des
mairies de l'Ouest parisien qui se
poursuivent ici aux pyramides du port
Marl il y aura notamment tout à l'heure
à suivre également des interviews avec
les personnalités politiques présentes
c'est toute la journée sur tv78 belle
journée à
tous